Kate Beckinsale is no stranger to kicking
butt and taking names.
Now, she's back with her most electrifying
performance to date in Amazon's "Jolt."
We have everything you need to know about
the "Jolt" ending right here.
Justin seems like the perfect guy when he's
first introduced.
He's charming, but he enjoys a good dirty
joke.
It appears as though he was specially tailored
to Lindy, and as it turns out, he was.
But right at the climax of her rampage against
Gareth Fizel, he's killed by someone else
before she can achieve her revenge.
It seems anticlimactic, but that's when we
get the big reveal that Justin is alive.
Not only is he still kicking around, but he
masterminded the entire operation.
It turns out he works for the government,
which wanted to kill Fizel but knew he was
too powerful to take out via the CIA.
That's where Lindy comes into play.
"Even the government isn't dumb enough to
go after Fizel.
Are you really that stupid?"
"You know what?
I think I am exactly that stupid."
The government couldn't kill Fizel, but some
woman with a revenge streak became the perfect
alibi.
Justin led Lindy right where he wanted her
to go, and she played her part perfectly.
One could say the entire operation was all
for the greater good, but all Lindy feels
is betrayal.
Justin may have the button to elicit electrical
shocks to Lindy, but it doesn't do much good
when Lindy overpowers her treatment, and as
expected, kills her former lover.
Naturally, Lindy's angry after she finds out
Justin got all the information on her from
Dr. Ivan Munchin, who developed the treatment
in the first place.
She visits him, and he's promptly arrested.
Before that, he mentions how they can move
onto the next stage, and it's not until the
end of the film where we get a better idea
of what that stage entails.
In a scene reminiscent of Nick Fury telling
Tony Stark about the "Avengers Initiative,"
a woman played by Susan Sarandon enters Lindy's
charred apartment.
Through clever editing, we realize that she's
someone who has a past with Lindy and was
there when she was just a child undergoing
experiments for her abnormal condition.
Now, it appears she wants to recruit Lindy
as part of some covert mission where her abilities
can be put to "good" use.
She doesn't say who she works for and what
kinds of missions Lindy would go on.
But chances are that said missions would likely
include killing scores of people.
“Through our work, you'll learn to harness
your rage and target the right people.
Humans are the most powerful, undetectable
weapon."
Susan Sarandon's cameo is the final scene
in the movie.
Given everything that transpires, you might
assume that reveal is the end of everything.
But you may want to stick around for a bit
longer once the credits start to roll.
The bonus scene doesn't have anything to do
with the plot, but it's a nice payoff to what
we saw earlier in the film.
When Lindy's trying to get more information
on her date's killer, she heads to a tech
shop to get more data from Justin's phone.
While she encounters a bunch of men on the
main floor, they take her to the back containing
their savviest programmer, who looks like
a hacker straight out of a '90s movie.
She's able to give Lindy the information she
needs, and as payment, Lindy hands over the
keys to her car, which just so happens to
be a McLaren Spider.
Naturally, the hacker is stoked on the new
ride in the mid-credits scene, and hopefully,
she has the chance to drive it around for
a bit before the police confiscate it for
its role in a high-speed pursuit earlier in
the film.
"Jolt" follows in a current trend of female-led
action movies all about the kind of agency
society allows women to have.
From the beginning of the film, we see how
much Lindy suffers due to her condition.
Rather than help her, Dr. Munchin is only
interested in testing the boundaries of how
intense her rage can get.
For this reason, he tells Justin about her,
which results in all of the mayhem that transpires
in the film.
Rather than attempt to recruit her, Justin
decides to manipulate her.
He terrorizes her emotions and makes her believe
the one person on the planet who understood
her was taken away.
Men control every aspect of her being, but
she regains a tiny sliver of it by the end
of the film.
Susan Sarandon's character appears to offer
her another route, but it's unclear how much
control Lindy will have in her life moving
forward.
Similar themes have come up with other action
films within the last few years, like "Captain
Marvel" and "Black Widow."
All three stories have to deal with women
forcing themselves to break free of the confines
placed on them from the patriarchy.
The trend likely started in response to the
#MeToo movement, and hopefully, it brings
about plenty of other projects with exceptional
female characters.
It certainly seems like the creative team
behind "Jolt" have hopes for "Jolt 2."
Susan Sarandon's character coming at the end
of the film hints at a whole world lying beneath
the surface of what Lindy knows, and another
adventure could very well be in store for
her.
It all comes down to whether Amazon wants
to go around for another ride.
"Jolt" just came out, so it's still a bit
early to tell if a sequel announcement is
in store.
Star Kate Beckinsale is certainly no stranger
to leading franchises with her turn as Selene
in the "Underworld" movies.
"Jolt" isn't based on any pre-existing intellectual
property, so it could be her version of "John
Wick," launching her into a killer role she
gets to play for years to come.
Regardless of the status of a possible "Jolt
2," fans can look forward to seeing Beckinsale
next in "El Tonto," written and directed by
Charlie Day.
The comedy should make for a decidedly different
pace than "Jolt."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.